okay uh let me ask you do we have a
phone to make a call or no I got a guy
my sergeant from the Army just texted me
from 20 from 1998 which by the way did
he did he ever find out
I have a story of his but I'm not going
to tell him maybe he'll tell it but
maybe he's not gonna tell it it's a
pretty crazy story but yeah here let me
let me get Felix if you're ready I'm
calling you tell me text me and tell me
yes I'll call you if you're ready
freaking wonderful how many times did
this guy scream at you
uh who this guy we're calling oh by the
way let me just tell you like do you
know what his size is Felix let me let's
see if he's on or listening to this
before I call this guy Felix is
oh my gosh Felix I got like a billion
stories did you did you say he was like
your corporate or what who was the
officer I was I was a a specialist he
was a sergeant and he was uh the
sergeant of supply all right let's see
if we can get a hold of this guy
how are you I'm doing pretty good how
about yourself Patrick I am doing good
man so what's the word what are you
thinking about what's going on here with
Afghanistan tell us tell the audience
who you are tell our relationship and
give us your idea about what's going on
in Afghanistan
you know so Patrick you know I I saw
your video and of course like you know
rest of the world I'm sure they're you
know they look at those those videos are
in shock and we have had a lot of family
and friends and even people I serve with
you know just kind of give a little bit
of my background like you were saying
I'm 20 years you know army retired uh I
have five combat tours three of them
being in Afghanistan or actually three
being in Iraq and one in Afghanistan so
I spent over four years of my life you
know in the Middle East uh between 2003
and 2011.
um our relationship you know I know me
and Patrick we serve together back at
Fort Campbell
um you know back in the day and um you
know I remember you telling me stories
about life you know in Iran growing up
and so you know as far as you know I
didn't get that perspective of living in
the Middle East until of course I spent
you know a good chunk of my life there
and um you know what I see is just
tragic you know it's it's unfortunate
and like I think I I put on your post
you know the fact that
um you know when I hopped on a plane I
remember the kernel briefing us you know
I'm there in the hangar at Fort Campbell
and was like how many of you guys been
to Iraq and you know of course I raised
my hand it was my second tour at the
time I did three tours total and he was
like a lot of you think you might know
what you're stepping into but like when
you go to Afghanistan it's a completely
different world and I'm like what's he
talking about and of course he said it's
kind of like the time you know the time
has stood still so
um until I was in charge of uh you know
Afghanistan detail where I was in charge
of basically 10 people we worked at
entry control points and so you know I I
dealt with them the every day I I fed
them I've trained them and it was just
just blew me away just how far they were
behind to the modern world so Felix can
you can you paint a picture for the rest
of us Iraq Afghanistan so modernized
education you know level of Lifestyle
what it was like maybe maybe paying a
picture for some that don't know
okay so I mean I guess the best way I
can put it is like you know my parents
originally grew up in Mexico right and
so when when as an American I'd go to
Mexico I would always be in shock of
like it's like a kind of a second world
country you know it's just not as
developed as America the technology
infrastructure and when I went to I when
I went to Iraq you know I kind of
identified it as kind of like I would
say let's say like Mexico but as far as
just infrastructure and the people and
education you know but maybe just a
little bit behind but when you go to
Afghanistan I mean Patrick it's
literally like you're going 3000 years
back in time wow I mean I know there's
do people say well they see the
buildings they see all that but I'm
talking about the everyday individual
the people the farmers the countrymen
the people that are out there they're
just literally behind
the modern world I mean even when I went
to Iraq I remember I was in charge of
interpreters so I remember they used to
tell me in Iraq now think about this
perspective that they were shut off to
the rest of the world they weren't
labeled to have uh uh only certain
channels right so Saddam Hussein
controlled the information flow that
came in there so their perspective of
Americans was completely different until
we were there and they saw how friendly
we were how they were there to help them
when they were given that or they don't
even they're shut off to the rest of the
world they don't know what the rest of
the world looks like if that makes any
sense
no of course now Felix when you when you
when you so you being there and amongst
all the other soldiers your run officers
you're around SAR Majors you're around
star in first class first sergeants
captains Colonels generals you're on all
these guys behind closed doors when it's
just sitting around shooting you know
you're just having a conversation
together what was the position of most
of the soldiers I'm talking more the
leadership not necessarily those who are
not leading was there is there position
amongst each other why the hell are we
here in the first place this should have
never happened what the hell are we
doing it's a waste of money you know we
could be back it's costing so many
people's lives or was it more from the
standpoint of we got to do our part to
help it's so necessary for us to be here
if we weren't here it'd be such a [ __ ]
show it'd be much worse what was the
language of leaders not victims and
complainers who don't want to be there
who can't wait to come back I'm talking
those who are aspirational leaders that
one they want to move up in the ranks in
the military what was the conversation
behind closed doors I mean I mean honest
honestly I I really feel that even as
Leaders even for for some of the even
the soldiers is like you know you you
know you might join the military for
different reasons and you know respect
for whatever they join for but once you
go there I mean you're a human Patrick I
mean you should know this right you know
you're like wow I I can't believe people
live like this or they or they have
lives like this and so you know I think
overall for a lot the sentiment is like
basically you're looking for is that we
realize that this is a real problem and
the fact that you know
um if we don't change and I think I I
send you a text saying that we need to
be there for a hundred years and I know
of course that's going to cost the
taxpayers a lot of money I know there's
people that have to go there and serve
but it's not just America's problem it's
the world's problem and I feel that got
it so Felix your position is that we
should have never pulled out of this
last week or you know 10 days ago we
shouldn't have pulled out
I mean from a humanitarian I mean I mean
I mean I'm sure as people look at in awe
right I mean of course I don't
um you know I don't write the checkbook
and I know that that's a cost to
American taxpayers and and I know
there's people that actually have to go
there and serve it and potentially risk
their lives but I think from a
humanitarian effort I mean you're
looking at it that these are people and
individuals like anyone else and until
you're there and see it and realize like
how good you have it here in America and
and you should know that you know you're
telling me the stories of you know when
you used to get bombed there in Iran but
it it it is just completely opposite out
there and it's like you know when you
see the kids and they're just like you
give them I I have a picture and I wish
I had it and this is in Iraq so this is
back in 2003 when I was convoying back
from
from being there and I remember stopping
on our Convoy like literally like like
five in the morning and some kid ran up
to me and I'm literally like giving and
he was just like can I get like he was
like water water and I gave him a bottle
of water and you thought I would have
given this guy you know this this kid
you know ten thousand dollars I mean
it's just a different mindset until you
have that experience
you know I think it's very moving and
and people I think overall even the
world I mean even as Americans I think
we're very empathetic to to people's
causes and of course we want to help a
lot of people and I know it's tough
someone's got to step up but I don't
think it's just America's responsibility
it's the world's responsibility hey
Felix oh sorry buddy go ahead this is
Tom this is Tom Zen I have a quick
question for you with your perspective
fighting the Taliban when you uh were
deployed there a what potential do they
have to actually change do you buy this
that they could be a different version
of the Taliban right now and B what
would realistically happen to any
Americans or contractors that work for
America as interpreter or anything else
what would happen to them if they were
left behind and not rescued
um I'll be honest I mean they the hatred
you know from from them is that's all
they know that's all they've been raised
on when I said they have to be there for
100 years you have to change a mindset
and that doesn't happen I mean think
about I was there in 2008 to you know uh
to 2009 for 13 months and you know it's
just completely different mindset you
have to go in there and change you know
it's a generational thing and when I say
100 years these people just think
different well I was I was mainly
wondering will the Taliban kill any
Americans or their contractors Left
Behind are their lives in danger if we
don't get them out and do you believe
the Taliban can change from my
perspective I would say yes I would say
yes they would be because they were
grown to to hate Americans and they
don't know any better I mean they they
think we're there to take the resources
and and change their way of life and
their ideology and and if they feel that
way I mean they don't they don't think
anything about us you know I mean it's
just their their language of how they
speak you know the follow-up question
for you here's the follow-up question
for you let's let's get a little bit
more logical so all this stuff you said
I'm fully with you I totally under I
remember when I got on the flight to
Lufthansa flight when I left Iran July
15th of 89 and we crossed the border and
the flight attendant says we can
officially serve alcohol everybody
started cheering and clapping because
they finally fell free you did not feel
free until it left the Iranian border
that's when we finally felt free so I
understand that part of it but the other
part of it some people may say well we
got 800 military bases in 70 plus
countries China's got one military base
by Suez Canal you know the Djibouti is
their base that they have in Djibouti
and we got all these other bases we're
spending all this money we're spending
all this taxpayers money should we go
out there and try to solve every
country's problems or should we let them
handle it themselves
I mean to be honest with you if it's if
it's you think it might not be our
problem but if they're harboring you
know terrorism and they they view us as
the enemy I mean just I mean whether you
want to believe it or not in our eyes we
never would have believed 911 would have
ever happened in our
prior to 9 11 that was unconceivable
Patrick but now it's it's it's
conceivable if that makes any sense of
course so so what I think in my
perspective is that whether we like it
or not you know and whether what it
costs if we if we ignore that then what
it could potentially Harbor will make 9
11 be even worse I mean think about what
happened with coven I mean God forbid if
they were had the intelligence or had
the technology to do to to Harbor you
know biological warfare if anything the
world is taught that that that's that's
that's the real threat you know what I'm
saying how do you how do you how
strongly do you feel about our military
today like today how strong do you feel
about the policies we're making today
with the military like do you feel safer
today than you did maybe 10 years ago 20
years ago tell me about how you're
feeling right now with being safer today
than it was 10 or 20 years ago
you know Patrick that's a great question
I'll share this with you uh my son is
currently in the Army my oldest son in
my fact he's he's serving at Fort
Campbell the place that we serve
together so
um you know I have friends that are
still in and the perspective you know
that I get is that you know
um the military is very Dynamic just
like it should be it's constantly
changing sometimes changing for the good
sometimes changing for the bad and just
the direction even when I got out you
know I got out in 2013 when I retired
after 20 years is that you know that
we're trying to be and this is you know
quote me if I'm crazy if you say that I
think we're just trying to be too you
know overly sensitive and unfortunately
the military is is is not a business
it's not a public organization I think
that's how they try to they're trying to
run it today to be able and politically
correct
um it's it's tough I mean I mean I know
our leaders have a tough job you know
whether you know I don't want to be uh
you know uh critical of the
commander-in-chief you know the best you
can do is say hey you know when I was in
the Army you know we're going to support
him 100 you know that's that's our job
especially being a leader and you know
um
it's
it's it honestly I think if we don't if
we don't
um
if we don't if we ignore that problem it
might not affect us now but it might
affect us 10 years from now so you think
another 911 is imminent and it just the
chances of it increased
yeah absolutely increasing I don't know
percentage-wise but I mean yeah I mean
uh I mean look at they they were waiting
they were waiting in in the wings for
for years for us to pull out
well Felix can I can I uh first of all
what I'm curious about is when you're
running for mayor Senate Congress
Governor when you when you're running
for some kind of political you know it's
funny when I moved to Texas when I moved
to Texas When I visit you in California
you were hinting about moving to Texas
yeah I don't know what they put in the
water here I'll be honest I absolutely
love it here in Texas
uh I mean just think about it I
literally live like probably 15 miles
where Tesla's building new Factory where
are you you're in Austin right if I
remember
yeah so if I move for May if I if I run
for for political office I think I'll
start off as mayor and then work my way
up do your thing about it I mean and
Felix listen you know shit's gonna come
out people are going to know how hard
you party by the way I don't you you
can't you can't hide that stuff because
you know when can I tell the people a
couple stories about you is that okay
Patrick absolutely honestly I'll be
honestly I tell stories to my to my kids
and you know 99 of them are positive uh
we went to spring break together but
we'll show that for another for another
which one is that is that is that La
Villa is that Panama City yeah I I told
him I told them when you were doing that
dance contest and then all of a sudden
yeah you jumped on the Bible contest I
remember that I forgot about that one
until you brought it up but we drove and
you remember when we got trophies in
your office what's crazy about this by
the way that club was a legit Club Club
La Vela was the whole MTV rap all that
stuff that they were doing it but we
drove this is how bad the situation was
we had a truck that only fed would fit
three people me Bradford and Felix would
sit in the front in the back for nine
hours four people were asleep
[ __ ] wow hey we would drive to obviously
this stuff is illegal we don't recommend
it kids please do not do this one of
these days the Romney thing that he had
to do you know that story is going to
come back for us
a guy you want to party with it's Felix
Felix is the guy you want to party with
Felix was a guy he would have 25 beers
the night before and he would go outrun
everybody the next day at five o'clock
in the morning that's freaking Felix he
would run five minutes miles six minute
miles just piss everybody off do all the
push-ups score perfect PT score and then
at night we'd have 12 Beers together by
the way Felix and I we watch cocktails
together Felix how many times have you
watched them do we watch that thing
probably like 100 times we watch
cocktails and Non-Stop and uh there's a
certain we watch what was it cocktails
what was the Patrick Swayze movie you
had Roadhouse we watched Roadhouse and
there's a few movies we would watch and
uh Patrick speaking of movies uh I I
want to kind of give you uh if you ever
want uh I know you're doing the your uh
your mafia yeah your mafia movie uh I've
got some good perspective of uh of
Goodfellas that no one's ever done
before if you ever want to sit down and
do it I'm good with it good Fellas I'm
your guy we will we will I am definitely
looking forward to that one of these
days you got to come out to Florida
we'll do something together but Felix
good to have you on brother give
everybody my best you said Florida you
moved to Florida now I'm in Florida
right I'm in Fort Lauderdale right now I
don't live in Texas anymore I'm in Fort
Lauderdale I've been here for uh what is
it now seven months six months seven
months we've been down here Florida well
I definitely know Anita said that she
wanted to do with the valuetainment
Torso we'll definitely uh we'll come out
that way to Florida some time and get
the tour and get a chance to catch up so
thank you for uh having me on the show
uh I wish my best for you and your
family and hopefully we'll have a chance
to catch up soon okay shut your body
take care bye-bye bye-bye what a
freaking guy man this guy he was a pool
Hustler sick player like when I took
maybe he was the best player on the
entire base out of 30 000 soldiers but
we'd go to a place here's what this guy
would do he's five six hundred twenty
five pounds Felix we'd go to a uh uh
billiard hall or pool hall right he
would start and he would start you know
talking trash to everybody and here's
what he would do he would say say
something say something like challenge
them I'm on the other side he says say
something you see that guy that guy's my
friend
it's always awkward man like do do
former veterans do you like when people
like thank you for your service when
they're like thank you for your service
is it weird you know but I tell you when
somebody does that it's also you want to
be appreciated you know you want
somebody to Value uh this is 20 years
you're talking about the Wonder Stories
you didn't talk about he was in a Humvee
when they went over and I I I don't know
what it was Felix there was like an
explosion and he was in there he saw
this stuff so it messes with you a
little bit so when you get out of it
right now he's been away from it for
nearly a decade but when you get out of
it at first it's mentally and
emotionally challenging so yeah but it
does uh it's always great when people
say that so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]